John Rambo has finally met his match: the
critics.
Reviews are coming in for Rambo: Last Blood,
which brings an end to the story begun with
1982's First Blood.
The general consensus: Rambo deserved a better
sendoff, and one with much less of a sadistic
streak.
"I'm gonna hurt ya real bad."
Over-the-top carnage is nothing new for this
franchise.
2008's Rambo similarly turned off critics
with its cartoonish reliance on dishing up
as much blood and guts as humanly possible.
But Last Blood's detractors — of which there
were many — were taken aback not only by
the extreme level of the violence on display,
but by some of the more troubling themes implied
by the film's plot, which involves Rambo crossing
the border into Mexico to search for a family
friend who has been kidnapped by sex traffickers.
Many of the flick's detractors noted that
political themes had always been present in
the Rambo series, even — perhaps especially
— First Blood, which dealt with the mistreatment
of Vietnam veterans after they returned home
from the war.
But the series' worldview seems to have changed
with the times, and not for the better, according
to Variety's Peter Debruge, who wrote,
"[Rambo: Last Blood is] another cruel and
ugly showcase of xenophobic carnage squeezed
into barely 80 minutes and packaged for export.
[The screenwriters] adopt the racist view
of Mexicans as murderers, drug dealers and
rapists [...] This character has always been
a mess of contradictions, representing on
one hand the permanent damage that military
service can do to one's soul, while simultaneously
suggesting what the ideal soldier looks like.
Rambo single-handedly wins the wars that America
can't.
And the blood isn't likely to stop here, or
anytime soon."
Tom Glasson of Concrete Playground concurred,
musing that the level of violence presented
in Last Blood — a step up even from 2008's
Rambo, in his estimation — was better suited
for a very different type of franchise.
Glasson wrote,
"[Rambo: Last Blood] a film that aspires to
be Logan, yet lands somewhere closer to The
Texas Chain Saw Massacre.
[Rambo] abhors violence, yet maintains a terrifying
arsenal of knives, guns and explosives.
And beneath [his] picturesque ranch is a straight-up
house of horrors, physically and psychologically.
But is the film still enjoyable?
Mostly, no."
Yet still, some reviewers were even less kind
— like The Guardian's Peter Bradshaw, who
absolutely leveled the picture in his review's
first paragraph, writing,
"This massively enlarged prostate of a film
can only make you wince with its badly acted
geronto-ultraviolence, its Trumpian fantasies
of Mexican rapists and hilariously insecure
US border, and its crass enthusiasm for rape-revenge
attacks undertaken by a still-got-it senior
dude, 73 years young, on behalf of a sweet
teenager."
Even some of the reviewers who recommended
the film seemed aghast at its violence, with
many remarking that even for a series which
has always hung its hat on wanton bloodshed,
Last Blood is a bridge too far.
Fred Topel of Showbiz Cheat Sheet wrote,
"It's funny to think how these movies were
always symbols of Hollywood's gratuitous violence.
They were bloody, but blood was the worst
they could show in the '80s.
[...] Last Blood takes violence so far it
almost has to be the last blood because there's
no more blood left.
Remember when the most graphic scene in First
Blood was when he cleaned his arm wound with
his knife?"
Again, this was a positive review, which indicates
that even some of those predisposed to expect
a heaping helping of bloody mayhem got a little
bit more than they bargained for.
Other critics posting positive reviews seemed
to recommend the flick in spite of themselves.
Vince Mancini of Uproxx, for example, penned
an assessment which read for all the world
like an absolute evisceration of the film,
right up until the point where the critic
offered his endorsement.
"Trump-era Rambo is essentially a human border
wall keeping out Mexican rapists and murderers.
[...] It's so genuinely horrific I'm convinced
there are real-life cartel videos celebrating
the torture of rivals that are less gory.
I was either howling with nervous laughter
or covering my face the entire time.
[...] This movie is the product of truly deranged
minds.
It's a must-see."
One thing viewers shouldn't expect is for
the film to do justice to its iconic main
character.
This idea was summed up most succinctly by
Harry Guerin of RTE, who wrote,
"This last post for the 37-year-old franchise
is a cheap and rushed send-off.
There are plenty of bodies but not much soul
[…] and although this is by far the bloodiest
of Rambo's rampages, it's also the least cathartic.
Don't remember him this way."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.